مشروع قانون سقف الدين يعبر اختباره الاول
بتمريره من لجنه القواعد في مجلس النواب
كخطوه اولى للتصويت عليه في المجلس قبل
ارساله الى مجلس الشيوخ
عدد من النواب الجمهوريين تعهدوا قبل
التصويت في اللجنه بفعل ما بوسعهم لايقافه
فيما هدد النائب شيبروي رئيس المجلس كابل
مقارتي بازاحته من منصبه اذا تم تمريره
الاتفاق هذه المجموعه ستعارضه سنواصل
محاربته اليوم وغدا بغض النظر عما يحدث
سيكون هناك حساب حول ما حدث ما لم نوقف
هذا القانون بحلول يوم غد بدوره دافع
مقرتي عن الاتفاق لست متاكدا مما يريده
الجميع لم نحصل على كل ما اردناه ولم يكن
بالامكان التحدث عن الميزانيه باكملها
خلال المحادثات وفي سعي لحج التاييد
لمشروع القانون اعتبرت مديره الميزانيه في
البيت الابيض واحدى كبار المفاوضين بشان
الصفقه شلندا يونغ ان الاتفاق مكسب للشعب
الامريكي
عندما نتحدث عن التخلف عن السادات فقد
انتصر الشعب الامريكي اليوم خاصه عندما
يصل المشروع الى مكتب الرئيس لاننا تجنبنا
ما كان يمكن ان يكون كارثيا
مساره الاتفاق ليس سهلا في ظل غضبي مشرعين
من اليمين الجمهوري وقلقي مشرعين من
اليسار الديمقراطي بسبب ما يرونه تنازلات
قدمها كل من الرئيس جو بايدن ورئيس المجلس
ابن مكارثي
بالتزامني مع ذلك يحجز قاده الحزبين في
الكونجرس الدعم للتشريع للتصويت عليه في
مجلس النواب اولا ثم مجلس الشيوخ حيث
يواجه ايضا معارضه جمهوريه
اعلن انه لن يصوت لصالح الاتفاق واقترح
بدلا من ذلك رفع سقف الدين ب500 مليار
دولار فقط والعوده الى طاوله المفاوضات في
غضون اشهر قليله لوضع اصلاحات اضافيه
للانفاق
وكان السنه الجمهوري مايكلي هدد سابقا
بعرقله الصفقه لعدم تضمنها اصلاحات كبيره
في الانفاق والميزانيه حسب تعبيره حسين
الطاوض العربيه واشنطن
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات